paysages inattendus dans la région
d'orléans
c'est la voie expérimentale de
l'aérotrain le chantier produits chaque
jour 80 m de poutres de béton hanté
renversé longue de quatre kilomètres
aujourd'hui la future voie paris orléans
fera 10 km au printemps prochain
cet élément de 20 mètres de long pèse 44
tonnes
c'est à gomez près de paris que depuis
plusieurs années les ingénieurs de la
société de l'aérotrain travaille à
mettre au point un engin commercial sur
coussin d'air
voici l'impression que vous auriez à 380
km heure dans ce prototype 0 2 de
l'aéroport
essai concluant pour ce prototype d'aero
train à réacteurs les ingénieurs étaient
très satisfaits monsieur kaplan
qu'est ce que cela veut dire pour les
usagers
ça veut dire que techniquement les
problèmes sont résolus
ça veut dire qu'on a commencé à faire ce
que j'appellerai déjà de l'industrie il
faut maintenant qu'on décide des lignes
ouvertes au public
car quand orléans a fait circuler un
véhicule dans très bonnes conditions
eh bien ça ne sert à rien pour le public
à quelle date public pourra-t-il voyager
sur air austral alors ça vous pensez
bien que la question n'est pas entre nos
mains si une décision était prise demain
nous sommes prêts sur tout ce qui
compose cette ligne aussi bien la voie
que vous avez vu que le véhicule
j'estime qu'il faudrait deux ans et demi
à partir du moment où le feu vert sera
donné c'est à dire les moyens seraient
fournis tout le monde est monsieur
bertin quelles sont les possibilités
offertes pour les véhicule à coussin
d'air guider mais elles sont très basses
puisqu'en définitive si vous voulez on
peut dire qu'ils vont de la vitesse la
plus basse jusqu'aux vitesse de 400
kilomètres à l'heure pour des passagers